it's Lawai time leave your entry in the
sir any crows episode why the white time
oh yeah
my favorite time Leviathan look Wow
everybody
last week I ate a child what did you do
last week I need more suggestions who
I'm gonna eat next I think this is
really how I'm gonna push my career to
the next limit you know I've done all
the controversies I've spent all the
cards what I need to do now I think what
I need to do what's right for me is to
eat more children especially to let me
know who I want to eat next and I will
do I will definitely do it I feel
stronger you know what I mean I feel
like the power has increased inside okay
let's just get into the memes guys
delete t-series to keep beatified number
one delete YouTube
I tried alright YouTube went down a few
days ago that was me trying I'm getting
desperate out t series is a million subs
away what do you want me to say thank
you for 67 million subscribers thank you
for 60 months imagine be peer pressured
by 9 year olds to eat paper and peer
pressure had nothing to do with it it
was my own free will Asian okay I wanted
to eat the child and it was great plus
there's nothing wrong with a 28 year old
man being pressured by a bunch of kids
to do something there's nothing wrong
with that okay like it or hate it that's
history right there when you go back to
playing video games 100% monetize oh
yeah we're trying out this new feature
where I want the premium ads okay I just
keep getting this stupid Tech Talk ads I
want the good stuff and YouTube seems to
scan the video from my transcription
if I would have called whatever
transcript and
and pick ads based on that so if I talk
about coffee
there will be additive coffee but I want
the premium self so I'm gonna say
expensive cars very nice luxurious cars
for nine year olds expensive nice fast
car I sure think I'm gonna buy a Tesla a
Tesla doesn't do advertising I'm
thinking about buying a car should I buy
a car guys what do you think were you
gonna buy a car
Who am I kidding Who am I kidding I'm
never gonna get those ads in my channel
I'm just looking for a Muslim wife there
is anyone have a Muslim wife could I
please find a Muslim wife has anyone
seen my Muslim wife let me know in the
comments we should add you guys it's
like YouTube relay ad relay something
pute said years ago are pewdiepie
submissions i said you have nothing else
on me do you nurse you've been in a coma
for eight years me I can't wait to be
fun play amnesia nurse that's perfect he
actually uploaded today yay Oh awesome
I can't wait for after eight years for
the PewDiePie amnesia remastered edition
I need to do the PDP ameesha amnesia and
Edition where I just hit my face with a
hammer and then I play the game again
like I actually had amnesia that'd be
epic
Peter should call my SIA his low wife of
course see this is where the good ideas
come from the wife my love wife the why
last week I ate you it's catchy
holy it all makes sense now I just need
to eat more people Ben Shapiro is a nine
year old confirmed okay this is epic
then you have been summoned we need Ben
Shapiro hosting next meme review that's
the only way I'm trying to call upon Ben
Shapiro this needs to happen objects in
the mirror are closer than they appear
Marcy and Felix having a child in making
tour review videos do you really think
we're that desperate no offense to
people that make these videos but
they're clearly just because if they're
popular it's like family vlogs
genetically engineered cat girls are
possible scientists say but we like
funding along everyone tweet elem us
right now the reddit app is social use
over time for hand-tight what happened
in the 1800's i guess cuz hentai means
pervert right so maybe in the 1800's
there were more perverts views is
trending in YouTube's official high atop
playlists I saw an icon
step aside we got big lasagne ten
million views ordered something from
dark web oh my gosh
is that like a curse box it's not like a
demon box I just got that freaking
chance this took days all right
[Music]
but what is it it's a toilet
what is it gonna be
[Music]
golden
you guys know what it is what I don't
know if it's meeting Pyrrha later
tonight
okay wait this goes on for four minutes
oh is that a model for ass oh my god
are you kidding me holy what
[Music]
what a legend yes
can we hit this model in s paper Benny
well done
absolutely phenomenal work look at him
now
just sitting it just sit in a chair
while playing horror games and yelling
at it I'm misty Oh beauty pie where he
used to review me laugh at them report
news reporter just make a rad video on
everything well played well played
keep it tuned to watch videos yes to
watch me use actually just look at
images with no sound like you think
you're clever you think you're smart do
you think you're prayed hard to swallow
pills Tik Tok saved us from the
musically immigration to YouTube and
thank you musically I mean tick tock
whoever you are
Satan you laugh you who who's my friend
dried hope it sees it very cool maybe
it's time maybe it's time to let the
beer flow again I feel it don't you
you're healing too don't you
oh it's happening why that why that last
Jedi was a bad movie in one image I
can't kill my evil father he still does
good in it those guys are bad this guy
is having a bad dream
they're going completely against his
character I paid a company to drive a
truck with this on it all day t-series
is done for thank you finally mr. Bies
has to - I fired in World War 2
I fought a criminal I fought in the
great mean war Catholics against
seedless watermelons seedless
watermelons against Catholics will you
fight or perish like a dog when t-series
is 1.6 million subs from surpassing
pewds fortnight oh my god you're right
you're actually right it's the only game
I haven't played it's the only game I
haven't touched I can't guys I can't the
world might implode I'm gonna put an end
goal at this video premium ads okay I'm
thinking about buying a new cell phone
the latest phone
I think Sherlock telephones I love
phones I'm thinking about buying the
phone right now
I keep forgetting about random shout-out
week I wanted to shout at nerd city is
an amazing channel if you know about him
you're probably nodding your head right
now cuz he definitely deserves more
subscribers put a lot of time and effort
into each video he did one on Jake ball
which was super interesting
it was digs deeper on subjects but makes
it in a high quality engaging way with a
lot of cool graphics and a lot of I
don't know I don't know how to critique
people's videos I just liked his video
so you should definitely check him out
and subscribe he definitely deserves it
I'm just gonna end that video there also
don't forget to check out the merch it's
only four days left so if you want the
meme review mark that's the time
everybody thank you guys for all the
support and thank you for submitting the
memes
[Music]